oh my god louise don't go down there
it's dangerous
did you mean to wave your arms all over
the place while falling into the hole
because if so you nailed it yes it all
went great wow
to think that this show originally
started as a pitch to be a family is
cannibals yes to you guys doing this for
10 years to now being a feature-length
film i mean first of all i just have to
say congratulations because it's huge
and i'm so
we did do it you guys did it we did do
it you did it you're sitting here and
you spent so much time with these
characters that i feel like they must
feel like a body part to you at this
point yeah
like a tale that people judge
i was like gene come to life i'm
freaking out my first question to you is
what part of you
lives in each of these characters that's
what i want to know like how did you
make this character your own and if you
pulled i'm a pop culture nerds if you
pulled anything from pop culture to
bring in your character i'd love to know
that too
john roberts i'd love to start with you
because i spent all my college years
watching your viral youtube videos of
you impersonating your mom yeah and
there's this one line you would say that
was um oh look at the ducks that just
kills me to this day
and i feel like there's so much of your
mom and linda there is so much of my mom
and linda and i've actually been doing
that impersonation of her since i was
probably like in
second third grade because she's from
brooklyn and she was always so funny
sounding to me
and uh she also had a thing of wigs that
she would let me play with and i would
pretend i was her going to like
bamberg is i don't know it used to be
macy's was bambergers you're probably
too young but um and you know all her
mom-isms you know that i use uh
they're it's very similar to
linda um
and i i i feel like it is like a limb a
little bit because it's my mom you know
so there's so much there's so much of
her in linda the best part of linda is i
i wanted to ask you is do you randomly
in your life just bust out in song
because she'll just walk into a kitchen
and be like cabinets cabinets i do i do
it with my dogs a lot i sing a lot of
songs to them
about food and just like kisses and
cuddles and stuff um yeah that's a lot
of improv songs all day long mostly and
john also has a music career that's
correct yes
yes of all of us he's the he's an action
singer check out his album kisses and
cuddles
i would buy that out
that's the follow-up songs for dogs
right
[Applause]
one of my song stink a sting comes stink
a little stinky to do
that's uh that's it that's an ear worm
they love that one
i think catherine o'hara goes off with
um oh he stole it
would love to know what part of you
lives in bob i don't think any character
on tv says oh my god more than bob
belcher does like
tell me what part of you lives in him
and how many like inflections of oh my
god
they still uh make me do it uh live uh
for every
take i'm shocked that they can't reuse
the
seven thousand oh my gods they have
already recorded
so uh and there's usually like three or
four for a show we were just discussing
that with the last episode that i've
said oh my god
four times and i suggested that maybe we
write one episode
where bob just says oh my god
the whole time
that's funny lauren and i go way back uh
with a bunch of different kinds of
characters that i did for other animated
shows for him
um
and they were much more aggressive and
uh
more pompous and loud
and when i started bob's it was really
fun to play a different role altogether
and let
the people who play the other characters
uh be the loud
uh
really the the humor of the show and so
um how does it relate to you i'm getting
how does it
i will say that
i will say that there's an interior uh
part of me that's a lot like bob he's
quiet and a little reserved and shy we
didn't see that a couple minutes ago you
mentioned you mentioned past and when
you poke the bear you've done with
lauren
and i want to go deep cut here real
quick for dr katz fans because a lot of
people say that your character ben cats
is kind of like a young bob so did you
bring anything from like dr katz into
bob
no i mean i actually think if i brought
anything to bob it was me being a dad uh
they sort of coincided so my son was
i probably like
five or six when the show started
uh so i was a dad at that point so i
borrowed from me i love that no
dan tina is and i hate saying this word
because we use it so much in society and
i feel like i'm to blame for it but
she's just so iconic and i feel like a
lot of people don't know that she was
originally supposed to be a daniel
and your dance so what part of you dan
lives inside tina and and who is she at
her core i mean tina is is kind of um
paradoxically both like quiet and
awkward and like confident cool
all at the same time um that i'm like
the confident cool part came from me i
didn't really know how to play quiet and
awkward i'm just kidding um
but yeah it was um
um but it yeah it's amazing how many
people are like i so so relate to that
character um like i really felt like
when they especially when they switched
from being a boy to a girl like it was
going to be almost like a gimmick
character like talks like me but it's a
girl and she says like weird things but
then the writers just did such a good
job of giving her more and more nuance
and personality and depth that like it
all of a sudden became something that
everyone's or not everyone but certain
types of people are like that that's
exactly me that's exactly what i was
like um which is so cool to hear that it
is everyone resonates with you um and
louise too i love louise's sort of
her lack of filter and her sense of
bravery is so awesome so obviously same
question to you kristen so cool to meet
you by the way like thank you for
entertaining me for my entire life and
also has her sense of bravery seeped
into your life
yes i i
louise is definitely um
me and my child like you know
it's so fun to be a child you're allowed
to be
um emotional and big and like make
mistakes and splash around and do dumb
things and have enthusiasm which is i
feel like adults if they have enthusiasm
everyone's like what's wrong with them
are they on some you know but children
get to be like yeah and it feels so fun
yeah look right now i look weird saying
that out of my as an adult person yeah
what are you on yeah exactly orange
juice yeah so it's fun that i get to be
that with louise um i would say
something that i that i try to do um
is not have regrets and i think louise
does that too but i
if it's something i feel like oh i'm too
scared i always think like okay you're
scared but are you gonna feel
regretful that you didn't do this
like future kristin is always like i'm
always protecting future kristen from
not feeling like damn it
um even if it doesn't work i just always
want to try it that's so beautiful
especially knowing that the message
people are going to get out of this
movie from louis specifically um with
you having said that so i love that
thank you thank you thank you
yeah thanks kristin
eugene all right gene is
the most hilarious he just is like
straight up facts um i love his love for
music which we also get to see in this
movie i know a fan actually gifted you a
keyboard so i'd love to know what you
brought to gene and what informed him
and are you a fan of music i mean i'm a
fan of music i can't really play music
um and in fact i would say jean sings
better than me because the way they
record it is i like repeat a line after
they do it and then they edit it
together so gene is like my dream singer
um
but i think that he i uh he has a like i
think a lot of enthusiasm
um
so maybe a certain love of jokes and
enthusiasm and then pop culture stuff
gene uh
mentions an un a disproportionate amount
of stuff that occurred in the 70s and
80s pop culturally and i believe that
might be as a result of my age
more than his
um so yeah i bring probably a lot of
love of simon and simon
and whatever else i've mentioned modesto
yeah and
solomon rushdie i think the second
episode we have an improv involving
uh that's that's my pop culture
reference salman rushdie uh but where we
i was getting a lot of foods will we
debate whether he wrote the line the
witch in the wardrobe
yes um yes
so that was like early on and then yeah
a lot of foods um a lot of the foods
that i mean read the satanic verses yeah
yes and he enjoyed it he was like
[Laughter]
he connected
um i forget if i've answered your
question but i did talk a bunch yeah you
did you did i love because those
references are the best part of gene and
i love that that's like really who you
are and what you bring to it so thank
you for that larry yes i love teddy
teddy's sense of loyalty and commitment
to the belchers is like every single
millennial girl's dream like if i could
have that sense of loyalty i didn't know
my life
what part of you is in teddy and why do
you think he is so loyal to the belchers
i think that he is
trying to find the thing that's missing
in his own life
and fulfilling it with the people in the
belcher family
and um yeah i think i connect with that
with this group of people i feel lucky
to work with this group of people
um
and i'm sorry i didn't real but
i think that it's a great group of
people here
and it is lucky to be able to work
especially in this industry with like
great people and just talking to you
guys right now you guys really are just
like everyone here really likes each
other yeah you could tell i i love you
guys um i also love all the lines
in like this show and the movie um i
used to produce the bachelor and my
favorite line ever was in season two
louise has to write an essay about
someone who's really important to her
and tina says well i'd write about the
guy who flies the helicopter on the
bachelor and i'm like that guy's
actually really important to me
and so that line has always stuck with
me my entire life as a producer because
i'm like batman is so important to me
what line i want to know from all of you
what line from your characters really
resonated with you maybe it's a line you
improvised or something that's just so
memorable and is stuck with you
um and feel free to act it out if you
want you don't have to i'd love to just
start with you dan and go this way i
mean i think the line um
i don't even remember what the episode's
from but um girls have uterus his voice
have deuteros
[Laughter]
i feel like if anyone else was saying it
would be such an awkward thing but it
kind of somehow flows naturally from
tina's thought process
um there's a in the episode i forget
which one it is but it's with tina it's
recently it's like last season
and tina's worried about her looks
whether or not she looks uh pretty
enough and louise doesn't know she's
like what are faces but like
like eye holes and a mouth hole like
just holds and like like beauty to her
is i feel like what beauty should be to
everybody which is who cares
um and i love that line i mean nora
smith wrote that she's you met her she's
great um
there was a line they animated it it
ended up getting cut but there was a
scene where the kids are in the diner
and they're excited to visit their
grandparents
and uh they're talking about why they
like to visit their grandparents and
like the things they let them do and
there was a line where gene says
uh they let they let me eat all the
tylenol pm i want
and they animated it and then they were
like you know
and i think you could even hear me like
laughing as um
that was fun that was a line that i will
hopefully work back into it one day
you'll you'll get to mention tylenol pm
yeah yeah at some point
now
you owe me 100 million
um i will have to go with i love you but
you're all terrible
that's on a t-shirt that my dad wears
yeah i feel like that
that's like the
like i was very early on in the morning
than the first episode of the show so
that sort of set the tone but that's as
cynical as bob
ever got i guess and he's he's gone the
other way since for me i think uh i when
linda said when i die i want you to
cremate me and throw my ashes in tom
selleck's face
that resonates with me because it's
actually my mother did say that
[Laughter]
we got her we actually actually met him
because my friend was on this show with
him and
but i think it might have changed to
hugh jackson now is that yeah you jack
jackman right
jacks beautiful the great thing about
actions is you can throw them in so many
celebrities
once you're cremated it's like really
jackson here we go a little for
[Music]
you know uh we'll ambush a lot of people
oh yeah all of my mom's famous yeah we
hope if this gets nominated and we're
gonna invite you into anything yeah get
ready
i think oh i think mine's a something
that they wrote and
i didn't realize how funny it was until
they it was animated and like we see the
movie uh the shows a year later and it
was something the writers wrote where
teddy's
driving and he's singing i wish my radio
worked i wish my radio worked or yeah
something to that effect
[Music]
so good uh there's so many good lines in
this movie in this movie i love this
movie because so many of your character
story lines just propel forward and i
want to know specifically from you
kristin and h john benjamin how you
think the bob's burgers movie
moved your character storyline forward
well because in this movie we talk about
why she wears the bunny ears which has
been the question the most asked
question for louise since the or since
we started and i know they've been
keeping that in their back pocket for a
big moment
and they decided to make it a movie
um so you get to see why she's wearing
them and
um
too much away and whether or not she
decides to keep and why
and yeah and she's a kid so you know
she's like it's just another moment of
being a kid where you have to evolve
your emotions a bit
um thank you
kristen you're
welcome sorry i just like you hadn't
been thanked at all in this interview i
just wanted to oh thank you
thank you
she actually did thank you yeah i think
naz has been like
not only he being praised but also just
a genuine fan it's been really
delightful yeah really i think uh bob
like for the i think bob probably in the
certainly in the beginning of the movie
for the first time has
uh shaken
uh more than he's ever been by what's
going on around him
yeah um
so i think that he
that's a big moment for bob and
it's not like that's not unfamiliar for
him he's always sort of under the water
a little bit trying to tread water with
the business and the family but
uh i think this one is the like
the biggest challenge for him and
uh
the kids oh really linda first linda his
rock of gibraltar yeah and then every
unsuccessful man is an unsuccessful
woman
and then i think
i do think that the kids in this really
do
especially in the movie pull
together and really try and help they
are kids and they they they
they can mess it up a little bit but
uh
everybody really pulls together for bob
in this one and he'll probably remember
that it's the best and it was probably
fun for you as a dad to bring that sort
of deadness to that to that yeah and i
also want to note that i am far worse of
a dad in real life than bob oh yeah i
love you you're all terrible
amazing um my last question to you guys
i'm so excited for everyone to see this
in the movie theaters yeah i'm a major
fan of cheeseburgers and just food in
general so i want to hear from all of
you what movie concession theater snack
would you pair with this film we'll
start with you larry
popcorn
i mean they sell it at all the theaters
they have it
good choice
popcorn
and uh edibles no um
i
[Music]
like
sometimes in the theater it's popcorn
and then something sweet like a gummy
something the swedish do you put a
god do you put it in the popcorn i've
seen people do that you do that
in the popcorn you put that do that she
knows you've done that everybody does it
do you want kids to be
you want little kids to be really high
when they see them
what would you have john i'd sneak in
food i'll i'll sneak in something
bologna oh like a
egg salad sandwich like chicken tikka
masala
yeah that's great
oh yeah right a little grinder like
ramps
um
okay so i created a new business
and i brought it to the movies she wants
us to stop it
i'm hungry with wine you can get wine at
the ark like oh did they shut down oh
that's right well you can go to the
falmouth cinema pub and get nachos or uh
salad or whatever
i would drink
with a drink sneaking a beer i'd say
don't get a large soda because you don't
want to miss a minute having to go to
the bathroom
i guess yeah that's really pragmatic
you